did you know that I lived in Minnesota
my okay so my DJ is I'm a fan too but he
he want he's the type to like when I'm
listening to music when I'm on uh we fly
everywhere all the time always you know
suffer I'm hungover or something I'm
always listening to like easy listening
music something chill relaxing he's
listening to Long YouTube videos
explaining someone's whole life and I
think he did yours at one point and
we're both from Minnesota so we kind of
got bonded over that but then I look I
tried to like earlier today look it up
and I couldn't find anything about it so
I just what do you mean well I guess I
just wanted your opinion I said San
Diego and that was about it but yeah
people leave out the eight years I lived
in Minnesota but I'm from Edina Adina
yeah yeah what years
so I'm guessing you're like a tiny child
of that time
well I mean a normal child
a four foot challenge I meant you were
very I mean you were very young you were
very young I mean I was another slam
you know I mean unintentional it's not
really it's but anyway yeah I was a tiny
child I was trying to compliment your
age and say you were very young I was
young I was a young guy yeah I was
probably I was born in 71 so when I was
one years old
um we moved to Minnesota so do you
remember anything about it oh yeah a lot
I remember it being cold I remember back
then there were not a lot of Asians at
all
there's I mean there's Asians there but
not not in the 70s not as many as
California okay yeah yeah it was weird I
remember
um now there's a famous story about me
being molested by a guy with Down
Syndrome oh that was there
that was there
so excited why did you oh my God that's
just yeah yeah well I think we I don't
know what's concerning it's not like
you're you're a man like are you good at
the spot like it's at the Alamo like
photos just like a toasted photos in
front of this thing or whatever I mean
no I just feel I feel guilty that we I
feel like I'm a part of it now no but um
and you know I go in and out if that
happened or not
now I'm now I believe it happened so
you're you think your brain's blocking
it out well like a couple of months ago
I said on this podcast that it I made it
up which I thought I did but then now
I'm thinking when I lay down in bed I I
think I see the hand so all these so all
the years before you ever did a podcast
or comedy or anything yeah
were you thinking about it in that era
because I think that would be well I
think when my brother was like really
because one time he heard me say it out
loud on a podcast and he goes really
because
um I remember that guy and I thought he
just you know I mean pulled out a
magazine and we just watched magazines
like porn magazines and he had candy but
I'm like I think that he you know I mean
touched me but I don't know for sure but
did he have Down syndrome for sure so so
you know every time that you your brain
every time that you think of a memory uh
whatever you think about that memory
when you
bring it back to the front of your brain
or whatever
whatever you think that time gets saved
it's not like you have the original
memory like kind of re Rises it like
rewrites itself every time you think
about something so people like this this
occurs where people will you know be
associating a night something negative
or they'll be in a bad mood when they
think of something and then they'll
start adding things to it or changing it
and then if like you can literally start
picturing real things that have like you
think happened that didn't happen
because your brain is remembering it
differently wow yeah I always equated it
to like my brain hat is like a writer's
room yeah maybe you have one Rider I
have 50 writers in my room and they just
just rewrite things you know what I mean
but that does ring true so that being
said then I'm going to go with it
probably didn't happen well I would
think maybe you had a little something
because I know that I've had experience
was where something happened and then
I'll like think about it over over time
and like add more to it or change the
story in my mind and literally you'll
literally picture it that way like how
physically see that happening wow and
then maybe something did happen but it
wasn't as significant as you thought so
you know I it's interesting I do
um Dr um therapy where you've done it
yeah or it's basically you get like
bilateral stimulation so that you access
like both sides of your brain so that
you can kind of tap into a memory much
clearer and you're right like a lot of
the things that I remember as a child I
sort of misremember and like kind of
frame differently as an adult either
because I needed to cope with it in this
way but like if I'm going to like the
core of it it's very different like the
memory is different or what happened was
truly different I just explain it
differently as an adult to myself and to
other people yeah and also it's like you
know I've been doing radio
since the 90s I mean you know I mean
I've done thousands and thousands and
thousands of hours and you have you know
you just make [__] up or you you know
what I mean or like you like if you told
a story to a friend or in a social
situation as is it just it's not no one
would give a [__]
do you agree or no like if you told a
story just the way it happened right or
do you do you think that human beings
embellish it so that people can go oh
that's a great story people embellish it
for sure yeah yeah
I don't know if I I in some cases I'd
say I do I have some really weird I'm
sure we all do but I've had some really
particularly weird long stories
yeah told another podcast and you're
here it's just I've said it too many
times but like but I have a lot of
stories that just sound ridiculous and
they're all factual and right right then
there are some where they're boring
enough where it's like oh I can't really
say all this without adding a little
sauce to it yeah sauce sauce is your dad
tall
uh so my dad was six six I mean six wow
I'm dumb six foot six foot six foot yeah
not six six double very tall what I was
gonna say is is my mom isn't tall either
but her all of her her siblings and her
dad and stuff are pretty tall so I do
have tall in the family